Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The person chiefly responsible for inciting the natives to rebel against the Romans, the person thought most qualified to serve as their leader and to direct the entire course of their campaign, was Boudicca. She was a Briton, a woman of royal rank, and possessed of much greater intelligence than is usually the case with women. First she mustered her forces, about 120,000 in all, and then she climbed onto a tribunal, which had been fashioned out of earth in the Roman manner. She was a woman of towering height and terrifying appearance, with fiercely flashing eyes and a rasping voice.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及深受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。煽动当地人反抗罗马人的主要负责人，被认为最适合担任他们领袖并指导整个战役进程的人，是布狄卡（Boudicca）。她是一个布立吞人，拥有王室血统，并且拥有远超一般女性的智慧。首先，她召集了大约12万人的军队，然后登上了一个按照罗马习俗用泥土堆砌而成的法庭高台。她身材高大，外表令人畏惧，目光如炬，声音沙哑。
A great mass of auburn hair fell tumbling to her hips. Around her neck she wore a large golden torc, and she wore a heavy cloak fastened by a brooch over a brightly patterned tunic. This was how she always dressed. Reaching for a spear to add force to her words, she spoke to her army as follows. You now understand from personal experience how different are freedom and slavery. Some of you, because you did not previously appreciate this, may have been seduced by the hunted promises of the Romans. But now, because you have tried both, you have come to appreciate how
一头浓密的红褐色头发垂落在臀部。她的脖子上戴着一个巨大的金色颈环，在一件色彩鲜艳的长罩衫外面，披着一件用胸针扣住的厚重斗篷。她总是这样打扮。她抓起一支长矛来增加语气分量，对她的军队发表了以下讲话。你们现在已经通过亲身经历明白了自由与奴役有多么不同。你们中的一些人，因为以前没有认识到这一点，可能曾被罗马人虚伪的承诺所诱惑。但现在，由于你们两者都尝试过了，你们已经开始体会到
terrible a mistake you made in preferring foreign occupation to your traditional way of life, and to realize that poverty without a master is always preferable to a slavery that makes you rich. For what shame have we not endured? And with what sufferings since these Romans first landed in Britain? So that, Tom, was Cassius Dio with the first detailed description of a Britain in history. And that's so much to unpick there in that reading, Dominic. It's just how, apparently, just according to Cassius Dio, it's just how Boudicca spoke, isn't it? Plotting a Brexit. So, just how Boudicca spoke, isn't it? Plotting a Brexit.
把异族占领置于你们传统生活方式之上是多么可怕的错误，并且开始意识到，没有主人的贫困总是胜过让你们发财的奴役。我们忍受了多少耻辱？自从这些罗马人首次登陆布立吞以来，我们又遭受了多少苦难？所以，汤姆，那是卡西乌斯·狄奥（Cassius Dio）留下的历史上对布立吞人的首次详细描述。那段阅读中有太多值得剖析的地方了，多米尼克。据卡西乌斯·狄奥所说，这显然就是布狄卡说话的方式，对吧？简直像在策划脱欧。所以，这正是布狄卡说话的方式，不是吗？在策划脱欧。
So, well, she is plotting a Brexit, isn't she? She is. According to her passage. The foreign occupation. Apologies to all female listeners for Cassius Dio's sexism. Yeah, that was poor, Tom. That was sad, wasn't it, from Cassius Dio? Yeah, so Boudicca is, I mean, she's probably the first vivid personality in the whole of British history. And Cassius Dio is describing this great rebellion that she leads in AD 60, a rebellion against Roman
好吧，她确实在策划脱欧，对吧？她是的。根据这段文字。异族占领。为卡西乌斯·狄奥的性别歧视向所有女性听众道歉。是的，汤姆，那可真够差劲的。卡西乌斯·狄奥的言论真让人寒心，不是吗？是的，所以布狄卡，我的意思是，她可能是整个英国历史上第一个性格鲜明的人物。卡西乌斯·狄奥正在描述她在公元60年领导的那场伟大起义，一场反对罗马
rule that almost succeeds. And, you know, we've been talking about the ambivalent attitudes that people, certainly in Britain, feel towards the Romans, but there's also kind of ambivalence towards Boudicca, isn't there? Because you could represent her as what I think she was, a kind of a freedom fighter, but she leaves this trail of destruction in her wake. Her forces commit appalling atrocities, as we'll hear. I think that she's one of the very few people to have two statues in towns that she incinerated. So there's a famous statue of her in London, which her forces burnt down, but there's also one in Colchester, which she also incinerated. Right. So a fascinating figure, Dominic.
统治、几乎取得成功的起义。而且，你知道，我们一直在讨论人们（当然是在英国）对罗马人的矛盾态度，但对布狄卡其实也有一种矛盾心理，对吧？因为你可以把她描绘成我认为她本来的样子——某种意义上的自由战士，但她在其身后留下一连串的破坏。正如我们所听到的，她的军队犯下了令人发指的暴行。我认为她是极少数在自己焚毁的城市里拥有两座雕像的人之一。所以在伦敦有一座她的著名雕像（伦敦曾被她的军队烧毁），在科尔切斯特也有一座，那座城市也被她付之一炬。没错。所以这是一个迷人的人物，多米尼克。
Yeah. An inspiration to arsonists everywhere, that if you burn down a city, you might get a statue. So I remember having done Boudicca at school, I think you were always expected to kind of empathize with her a bit, weren't you? She was a kind of heroic figure. And in the popular imagination, hasn't she become conflated a little bit with the figure of Britannia? Do you think on the kind of chariot, the wild hair, the flashing eyes, the spear, all of that kind of stuff? Do you not think there's an element of that? I think because we have two detailed accounts of her rebellion, Cassius Dio, who we referred to, but also Tacitus, the greatest Roman historians, and whose texts become readily available in the Renaissance and then through into the modern
是的。对各地纵火犯的鼓舞——如果你烧毁了一座城市，你可能会得到一座雕像。所以我记得在学校里学到布狄卡时，我想大家总是被要求对她产生一点共鸣，对吧？她是一种英雄似的人物。而在大众想象中，她是不是已经有点和不列颠尼亚（Britannia）的形象混为一谈了？你觉得比如战车、狂野的头发、闪烁的目光、长矛，所有这些东西？你不觉得有这种成分吗？我想是因为我们有关于她起义的两份详细记录：我们提到过的卡西乌斯·狄奥，还有塔西陀（Tacitus），他是最伟大的罗马历史学家，其著作在文艺复兴时期及之后的现代
period. For British scholars, but also for the British generally, to have this incredibly dramatic figure at the kind of wellsprings of our history is great. And you're right that, of course, there is a kind of parallel between the figure of Boudicca and the figure of Britannia, who we referenced yesterday, first appears as someone who is being assaulted by a kind of buff Claudius. And as we will see, what prompts Boudicca to her revolt is precisely sexual violence. So yeah, I think there's lots to unpick here. I'm glad you didn't unpick that opening impression. I mean, that's surely something for a bonus episode. I've just left that.
时期变得广为流传。对于英国学者以及普通英国人来说，在我们的历史源头上拥有这样一位极其戏剧化的人物是很棒的。你是对的，当然，布狄卡的形象与我们昨天提到的不列颠尼亚的形象之间存在某种平行关系——后者最初以一个遭到某种粗鲁的克劳狄乌斯（Claudius）侵犯的形象出现。正如我们将看到的，正是性暴力促使布狄卡发动了起义。所以，是的，我认为这里有很多值得剖析的地方。我很高兴你没有剖析那个开场印象。我的意思是，那绝对是加更节目该聊的内容。我刚刚把它搁置了。
Yeah, that's between me and my therapist, Tom. To float. So let's have a bit of context. To float in the pan. Let's have a bit of context. Last time we heard about how the Romans invaded in AD 43 under Claudius, and you described how they pacified the kind of south and midlands of the island of Britain. They beat the Catavoloni, so that was the most powerful kingdom.
是的，那是属于我和我的心理医生的事，汤姆。留着以后再说。让我们来点背景知识。随便提提。让我们了解一点背景。上次我们听说罗马人如何在公元43年在克劳狄乌斯的带领下入侵，你描述了他们如何平定不列颠岛南部和中部地区。他们击败了卡塔沃洛尼人（Catavoloni），那是当时最强大的王国。
And they turned their capital, Camulodunum, into a Roman colony, a colonia. And they settled their veterans there. And they built a big temple to Claudius, to the conqueror. Give us a bit more context. What else has been happening? Just to put this into some perspective. So Camulodunum, present-day Colchester, which has become this colony, this kind of showcase for Roman civilization. It's confusing because although it was a Catavelonian capital,
他们把首都卡穆洛杜努姆（Camulodunum）变成了一个罗马殖民地（colonia）。他们在那里安置了退伍军人。他们为征服者克劳狄乌斯建造了一座宏伟的神庙。给我们多讲点背景。还发生了什么？好把这一切放在一个视角中来看待。所以卡穆洛杜努姆，即今天的科尔切斯特，已经变成了这个殖民地，罗马文明的一种展示橱窗。这很令人困惑，因为尽管它是卡塔沃洛尼人的首都，
the Catavelonians had been an imperial power themselves and had conquered it from the Trinovantes, who were their neighbours. And so it's the poor Trinovantes who really suffer from the exactions of the settlers in Camulodonum. So they're very miserable. Whereas the Catephaloni, who are the people who the Romans defeated, they're absolutely fine. They're having a great time. They've got their main kind of settlement, Verulanium. It's been pronounced Municipium, which means that all the elected magistrates in there become Roman citizens. They've started to build baths, all this kind of stuff. So they're very happy. And also to the south, there is the kingdom of the Atrabates, very stable, ruled by the very solidly pro-Roman Togedubnus, who may well be the guy who lives in
但卡塔沃洛尼人自己曾是一个帝国强权，从他们的邻居特里诺凡特人（Trinovantes）手中夺取了这里。因此，真正遭受卡穆洛杜努姆殖民者残酷榨取的，正是可怜的特里诺凡特人。所以他们非常痛苦。而卡塔沃洛尼人——也就是被罗马人击败的那个族群——他们过得相当好。他们过得很棒。他们主要的定居点维鲁兰尤姆（Verulanium）已被宣布为“自治市”（Municipium），这意味着那里所有选举产生的地方法官都成为了罗马公民。他们开始建造浴场以及诸如此类的各种设施。所以他们非常高兴。此外，在南部，阿特拉巴特人（Atrabates）的王国非常稳定，由坚定亲罗马的托格杜布努斯（Togedubnus）统治，他很可能就是住在
the palace of Fishbourne, the kind of great villa. So the Castellani, the Atrabates or whoever they are now, they're pro-Roman. So that's a big, solid Roman block. And basically the Romans are confident that the southeast is secure, which is why there was a legionary base in Camulodonum that's now been withdrawn and it's been given over to kind of veterans. Meanwhile, beyond the kind of lowland southern Britain, in the north, so kind of Yorkshire, Lancashire, all that, that is the territory of a tribe called the Brigantes, who are ruled by a queen called Cartamandua, who's a kind of great survivor. We'll be coming back to her later. And in Wales, an absolutely brutal, one might almost say genocidal, war of pacification is happening there, led by the governor of Britain, Suetonius Paulinus, who is probably the most effective
菲什本（Fishbourne）那座大型豪华别墅里的人。所以卡塔沃洛尼人、阿特拉巴特人或无论他们现在是谁，都是亲罗马的。因此这是一个庞大、坚固的罗马板块。基本上，罗马人确信东南部是安全的，这就是为什么卡穆洛杜努姆原本的军团基地现在已经撤出，并被交给了退伍军人们。与此同时，在低洼的南部不列颠之外，在北部——也就是约克郡、兰开夏郡一带——是一个名为布里甘特人（Brigantes）的部落领地，由一位名叫卡塔曼杜阿（Cartamandua）的女王统治，她是个非常顽强的生存者。我们稍后会再谈到她。而在威尔士，一场极其残酷、几乎可以说是种族灭绝式的平定战争正在那里上演，由不列颠总督苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯（Suetonius Paulinus）领导，他可能是整个罗马帝国最能干的
general in the whole Roman Empire, which is why he's been sent to Britain. And he's given the Druids on Anglesey a hell of a kicking. Yes, exactly. Suetonius Paulinus has gone to, well, he ends up in Anglesey. I mean, it's a long way from southeastern Britain. And he can do that basically because he feels that the southeast has been successfully pacified and the romans as they usually do when they conquer a territory you know they apply the carrot and the stick so the carrot is the villas that they give to leading collaborators the uh the civic adornments that they give to give a tartase they're called so that these are roman style urban foundations
将军，这就是为什么他被派往不列颠。他把安格尔西岛（Anglesey）上的德鲁伊（Druids）狠狠教训了一番。是的，完全如此。苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯去了——嗯，他最后到了安格尔西岛。我的意思是，这离东南不列颠很远。他之所以能这么做，主要是因为他觉得东南部已经被成功平定，而且罗马人像往常征服领地时一样，你知道的，他们软硬兼施。所以，“胡萝卜”就是他们送给主要合作者的别墅，是他们赐予那些被称为“西维塔斯”（civitas，意指行政区）的自治首府的城市装饰物——这些都是基于集会场所的罗马风格城市基建。
based on meeting places. So Verulianum would be an example. Camulodonium would be another. You'd have your bath and your forum or whatever. Yeah, all that stuff. The stick, of course, is the risk that you will be slaughtered, enslaved, raped if you oppose Roman rule. And so essentially it creates for the Britons a choice. You can collaborate and have a nice bath, or you can fight and end up
维鲁兰尤姆就是一个例子。卡穆洛杜努姆是另一个。你会有你的浴场、广场之类的一切。是的，所有这些东西。当然，“大棒”就是如果你反抗罗马统治，你将面临被屠杀、奴役、强暴的风险。所以，这基本上给布立吞人创造了一个选择：要么合作并洗个舒服的热水澡，要么反抗并最终
either dead or in shackles. That's a no-brainer, but clearly I don't love freedom as some people do. Well, yes. Well, people can draw their own lessons on that, Dominic. Yeah, they can indeed. So let's talk about Boudicca. When I did this at school, I was always told she was the queen of a people called the Iceni. I noticed that you pronounced it I-kenny in the last episode episode. I looked it up and you're quite right. I am. Thanks, Dominic. But everybody in England will call it the Iceni. So, you know, just to put that on the record to explain to people that you're not talking about some random other. You're a stickler for the little details, aren't you, Tom? Well, it's also because there's an important road, a kind of trackway, very, very ancient, much older than the Icenane, called the Ickneald Way.
死路一条或沦为阶下囚。这不用脑子想也知道，但显然我并不像某些人那样热爱自由。嗯，是的。好吧，人们可以从中得出他们自己的教训，多米尼克。是的，确实如此。那我们来谈谈布狄卡。我在学校学到这个时，总是被告知她是一个叫做爱西尼（Iceni）的部落的女王。我注意到你在上一集中把这个词发音为“I-kenny”。我查了一下，你完全是对的。我是。谢谢你，多米尼克。但英格兰的每个人都会叫它“Iceni”。所以，你知道，只是为了把它记录在案，向大家解释你并不是在谈论什么别的随机事物。你是个注重微小细节的人，对吧，汤姆？嗯，这也是因为有一条重要的道路——一条非常非常古老的小路，比爱西尼人还要古老得多，叫做伊克尼尔德之路（Ickneald Way）。
The Ickneald Way. Yeah, I know that road. So it goes from the Icanean territory, which is in the north of East Anglia, all the way down to Wiltshire, so my neck of the woods. And it's possible that that name comes from the Icane. That'd be brilliant, wouldn't it? And the Ickneald Way will have an important part to play in this story. So not only has everyone in England been pronouncing the name of her tribe wrong, she's also not even a queen. Is that right?
伊克尼尔德之路。是的，我知道那条路。所以它从东盎格利亚（East Anglia）北部的爱西尼领地一直延伸到威尔特郡（Wiltshire），也就是我熟悉的那片地方。这条路的名字有可能就来源于爱西尼人。那太棒了，不是吗？而伊克尼尔德之路在这个故事中将扮演重要的角色。所以，不仅英格兰的每个人都把她部落的名字读错了，她甚至也不是女王？是这样吗？
No. So not in her own right, like Cartamundur is. So she's the consort of, well, the Romans call him a king, a rex, whatever. I mean, he's the kind of the head honcho of the Icani, a man called Prasutagas. So it's possible that Boudicca is, you know, she's come from another tribe. And the Icani are a very distinctive people. So it's telling that we haven't really talked about them to this point because they haven't really intruded on the narrative. They're not really a unitary kingdom. They're a kind of a confederation, a kind of tribal league, pretty
不。所以她不是凭自己的权利成为女王的，不像卡塔曼杜阿那样。所以她是——嗯，罗马人称他为国王，一个“雷克斯”（rex），随便怎么说——爱西尼人的头头，一个名叫普拉苏塔加斯（Prasutagas）的男人的妻子。所以布狄卡有可能，你知道的，她来自另一个部落。而爱西尼人是一个非常独特的族群。所以很有说明意义的是，我们到目前为止还没有真正谈到他们，因为他们并没有真正闯入叙事中。他们并不是一个真正统一的王国，而是一个松散的联合体，一种部落联盟，相当
cohesive, but with separate subdivisions, kind of separate cantons, if you want to call them that. They have had contacts with Rome pretty early on. It's probable that they are one of the tribes that sent ambassadors to submit to Julius Caesar when he invaded back in 54. But it is striking, based on the archaeology, that the Icani are much, much less in hock to Roman culture than the other major tribal groupings. And so, you know, you find there are very few Roman coins there, very little evidence of kind of luxury foreign goods, no amphorae of wine, so on, things like that. And so the question is, why should this be? And one answer might be their geographical circumstances. You know, they're further north,
有凝聚力，但有独立的分支，如果你愿意的话，可以称之为独立的行政区。他们很早就与罗马人有了接触。很可能他们在公元前54年尤利乌斯·恺撒（Julius Caesar）入侵时，就是派遣大使臣服的部落之一。但根据考古学证据，引人注目的是，爱西尼人受罗马文化的侵蚀要远远少于其他主要的部落集团。所以，你知道，你会发现那里很少有罗马硬币，几乎没有外来奢侈品的证据，没有装葡萄酒的双耳罐等等诸如此类的事物。所以问题是，为什么会这样？其中一个答案可能是他们的地理环境。你知道，他们更靠北，
they're surrounded for much of their territory by the North Sea. And also the fens, which at this time are very, very impassable for large stretches. You know, they haven't been drained. So there's huge kind of swamps bordering the southern reaches of their territory. And you can kind of tell the way in which they're distinctive by looking at their coins, which we talked about in the previous episode. These are markers of a kind of cultural distinctiveness for the first time. You can work out maybe what the ideology is of a particular tribal grouping by looking at them. And the thing that's striking about the Ikenayan coins, well, there's lots of stuff that's striking about them, but one of the really striking things is that unlike the coins of other British tribes, they feature very heavily the wolf, which by this point, it's quite rare in lowland
他们的领土大部分被北海包围。还有沼泽，在当时，很大一部分地区都极其难以通行。你知道，它们还没有被排干。所以他们的领地南部边缘毗邻着巨大的沼泽。你可以通过观察他们的硬币看出他们独特的方式，我们在上一集中谈到过这一点。这些是第一次出现某种文化独特性标志的东西。通过观察它们，你或许可以弄清楚某个部落集团的意识形态是什么。而爱西尼硬币最引人注目的一点——嗯，有很多引人注目之处——但其中极其引人注目的一点是，与其他人不同的是，布立吞部落的硬币大量以狼为特征，而到这个时候，在低洼的
Britain by this point. The wolf is very, very sinister. I've got one of their coins with a wolf on. There's a brilliant description of it by Duncan McKay in his wonderful book, Echolands, which is a superb book about Boudicca, came out last year. And he writes about this wolf. It's an emaciated, beak-jawed, spike-eared and spindle-limbed creature that must have moved more like a spider than anything mammalian. So very sinister. And it's shown with birds that are
不列颠，狼已经相当罕见了。这种狼非常非常不祥。我有一枚印有狼的他们的硬币。邓肯·麦凯（Duncan McKay）在他去年出版的关于布狄卡的极其精彩的书《回音之地》（Echolands）中对此有极其精彩的描述。他这样写这只狼：这是一只瘦骨嶙峋、长着喙状下巴、尖耳朵和纺锤般四肢的生物，它的移动方式一定更像蜘蛛而不是任何哺乳动物。所以非常不祥。它与
clearly associated with the fens, so lapwings, bitterns, so on. And this gives the sense that the wolf is a fen dweller which in germanic would be fenrir oh i love that and fenrir in norse mythology of course is the great wolf that at the end of the world devours the sun and there's another kind of echo or perhaps foreshadowing of norse mythology that another series of early Icanaean coins features this strange mask-like male head with a single eye. There's an Oxford numismatist called Daphne Nash Briggs who's written a lot about the Icanaean coins in a very, very stimulating way. She writes about this eye, that its lids are either closed or firmly sewn shut, which of course may remind listeners of Odin, the one-eyed god who rips his eye out. Gave up his eye for wisdom.
明显与沼泽相关的鸟类一起出现，比如田凫、麻鳽等等。这就给人一种感觉，这只狼是一个沼泽居民，在日耳曼语中就是“芬里尔”（Fenrir）。哦，我太喜欢这个了！而在北欧神话中，芬里尔当然是那只在世界末日吞噬太阳的巨狼。还有另一种北欧神话的回响或某种预示，另一系列早期爱西尼硬币上印有一个奇怪的、面具般的、带着单眼的男性头像。有一位牛津大学的钱币学家达芙妮·纳什·布里格斯（Daphne Nash Briggs），她以非常非常富有启发性的方式写了大量关于爱西尼硬币的文章。她写到这只眼睛时说，它的眼睑要么是闭着的，要么是被牢牢缝上的，这当然可能会让听众想起奥丁（Odin），那个挖出自己一只眼睛的独眼神。为了智慧而放弃了自己的眼睛。
I mean, what's even more fascinating is that Nash Briggs argues that Icanaean coins, in addition to having Latin and Brittonic language, also has Germanic language. When you say argues that, is that because it's up for debate? You can't really tell what it says. So it's massively up for debate. And I think that other scholars would say these seeming foreshadowings of Norse mythology, the details of Norse mythology come millennia later.
我的意思是，更令人着迷的是，纳什·布里格斯认为，爱西尼硬币除了有拉丁语和布立吞语之外，还有日耳曼语。当你这么说的时候，是因为这还有待商榷吗？你真的看不懂上面写的是什么。所以这极具争议。我认为其他学者会说，这些看似对北欧神话的预示——北欧神话的细节是在几千年后才出现的——
It's most improbable that these stories were current at that time. The linguistic evidence is also furiously debated. But I mean, My gut feeling is that it's perfectly plausible that the Icani, because they are open to the North Sea in the way that, say, Wales or Cornwall had been open to Celtic influences coming up from the Atlantic, seems to me perfectly plausible that there might be a kind of Germanic substratum in their culture, and that perhaps these coins reflect traditions that are percolating around long, long before the Viking period. It's plausible that there are traders and things crossing the North Sea,
这些故事在当时流传的可能性极小。语言学证据也受到了激烈的争论。但我的直觉是，完全合乎情理的是，爱西尼人——因为他们面向北海敞开，就像威尔士或康沃尔曾面向从大西洋上涌的凯尔特人影响敞开一样——在我看来完全合乎情理的是，他们的文化中可能存在某种日耳曼语的底层，并且这些硬币也许反映了在维京时期之前很久很久就在四处流传的传统。在这个时期，穿越北海的商人和诸如此类的人是合乎情理的，
isn't it, in this period? Maybe not at the same volume as centuries later, but there must have been sea contacts between East Anglia and Holland or Denmark or Norway or whatever? I mean, it seems improbable that there wouldn't be. And it perhaps offers a clue as to where Icanian culture is coming from, that perhaps this is why they are less influenced by what's happening in Gaul, but more influenced perhaps by Germanic traditions that are crossing from Saxony or from Scandinavia or whatever. And is it not the case that they are consciously more isolationist and more exceptionalist, so that they are deliberately restricting
不是吗？也许不像几个世纪后那样规模庞大，但东盎格利亚与荷兰、丹麦或挪威等地之间一定有海上联系吧？我的意思是，如果没有，那才叫不可思议呢。它也许提供了一条线索，说明爱西尼文化来自何方——也许这就是为什么他们受高卢（Gaul）正在发生的事情的影响较小，而更多地受来自萨克森（Saxony）、斯堪的纳维亚或其他地方的日耳曼传统的Ảnh响。难道不是这样吗：他们是有意更加孤立主义、更加奉行例外论，从而刻意限制
Roman imports and resisting the advance of Roman culture, do you think? Again, this is an argument that Daphne Nash Briggs pushes. She points out that there must be Roman coins coming in because there's gold and silver that's being reminted. But it seems that they all seem to have been deliberately melted down and that there must almost certainly be conscious restrictions on the import of wine. And she suggests that it was an attempt, quote, to mitigate destructive competition amongst armed aristocrats. And if that's the case, then it must be Prosutagas who is responsible for that. It suggests that he's walking a very delicate tightrope because the
罗马进口商品并抵制罗马文化的发展？你觉得呢？同样，这也是达芙妮·纳什·布里格斯力推的一个观点。她指出，一定有罗马硬币流入，因为有金银被重新铸造。但似乎它们全都被刻意熔化了，而且几乎可以肯定，进口葡萄酒一定受到过有意识的限制。她暗示，这是一种“试图减轻武装贵族之间破坏性竞争”的尝试。如果是这样的话，那一定是由普拉苏塔加斯负责的。这表明他在走一条非常微妙的钢丝，因为
probability, and again, we're talking in terms of probability or possibility here, is that he was a hostage in Rome. The royal children of British tribes seem to have been sent to Rome as a matter of course. So he would be conscious of Roman power and Roman culture. But at the same time, he clearly seems to have had a role in Icanaean life that was more than that of just a king. He seems to have held a kind of priestly status. And it's likely that Prosutagas is not a proper name, but a title. Because based on the evidence of his coins, it seems to have meant something like Pontifex Maximus, a high priest, the man who mediates between his people and the gods. I think it's
可能性——同样，我们这里是在讨论可能性或概率——是他曾在罗马当过人质。布立吞部落的王室儿童似乎例行公事般被送到罗马。所以他会对罗马权力和罗马文化有所认识。但与此同时，他在爱西尼人生活中的角色显然不仅仅是一个国王。他似乎担任了某种祭司的身份。普拉苏塔加斯很可能不是一个本名，而是一个头衔。因为根据他硬币上的证据，它似乎意味着类似于“最高祭司”（Pontifex Maximus）的职位，即大祭司，一个在自己的人民和诸神之间进行调解的人。我认为在那个背景下，
telling in that context that Boudica too, or more properly Boudega, I gather, means she who brings victory. This too may have been a title rather than a name. And it suggests that you have the victory giver marrying the man who is the mediator between the gods. There is, Dominic, dare I say, a sacral dimension to this marriage. We love a sacral dimension on the rest of history. We so do. And we can actually identify a place where this holy couple, because I think we should think of them as a kind of a holy couple, a sacral couple, where they may have presided. Today it's on an industrial estate called Fisson Way. Duncan McKay in his book has a brilliantly funny account of him trying to track down this place of eerie portent, and there's crisp wrappers
布狄卡——或者更准确地说布迪加（Boudega），我了解到——意思是“带来胜利的女性”，这也可能是一个头衔而不是名字。这表明胜利的赐予者与作为神明调解人的男人结为夫妻。多米尼克，我敢说，这场婚姻具有一种神圣的维度。我们喜欢《历史的余烬》中的神圣维度。我们确实喜欢。而且我们实际上可以确定这个神圣夫妇——因为我认为我们应该把他们看作某种神圣的夫妇、神圣的伴侣——可能曾主持过仪式的地方。如今它在一个名为菲森威（Fisson Way）的工业园区里。邓肯·麦凯在他的书中对他的这次经历有一个极其滑稽的描述：他试图追踪这个充满诡异预兆的地方，却发现周围到处都是
everywhere. When the industrial estate was being developed, archaeologists went in and they found that in the 50s AD, this massive artificial oak grove had been built there. So great serried ranks of posts and fences sticking up, deliberately trying to look like a grove of oaks. So Nash Briggs says it's a symbolic grove. You have, I mean, almost intangible a sense of the Icani as a people for whom the dimension of the supernatural is everywhere and is part of their political dynamics. And I think that all of this helps to explain why the Icani, unlike the Catephaloni or the Trinovantes, are able to maintain their independence from Rome. Prosutagas is clearly a brilliantly competent politician. He's able to reassure the Romans that his independence offers them no threat. And at the same time, he's able to dampen down all the kind of ambitions among his fellow Icaneans,
薯片包装袋。当工业园区开发时，考古学家介入并发现，早在公元50年代，这里就曾建造过这个庞大的、人工的人造橡树林。一排排密密麻麻的柱子和篱笆竖立在那里，刻意试图看起来像一小片橡树林。所以纳什·布里格斯说这是一个象征性的树林。你对爱西尼人有一种几乎难以言喻的感觉，认为对他们来说，超自然的维度无处不在，并且是他们政治动态的一部分。我认为所有这些都有助于解释为什么爱西尼人不像卡塔沃洛尼人或特里诺凡特人那样，能够保持他们对罗马的独立性。普拉苏塔加斯显然是一个极其称职的政治家。他能够向罗马人保证他的独立对他们不构成威胁。与此同时，他能够平息所有同胞爱西尼人当中的野心，
even to the extent that in 47, there's a kind of Icanean rebellion. But the Romans still don't, they suppress it, possibly with the help of Pros, but the Romans still don't. They suppress it, possibly with the help of Prosutagus. We don't know whether his collaboration went that far, but it is amazing that Prosutagus is able to maintain the independence of his people, even after an uprising like that. But of course, the risk that faced the Icanean is that when Prosutagus dies, what will happen then? Tom, I have to tell you, I've just been looking at Fison Way. It doesn't look very mystical. No, not sacral.
甚至在47年还发生过某种爱西尼起义。但罗马人仍然没有——他们镇压了它，可能在普的帮助下——但罗马人仍然没有。他们镇压了它，可能在普拉苏塔加斯的帮助下。我们不知道他的合作是否达到了那个程度，但令人惊奇的是，普拉苏塔加斯甚至在经历了一场这样的起义之后，仍能维持他人民的独立。但当然，爱西尼人面临的风险是，当普拉苏塔加斯去世时，接下来会发生什么？汤姆，我不得不告诉你，我刚才看了看菲森威。它看起来一点也不神秘。不，一点也不神圣。
It looks like a brilliant place. If you're in Thetford and you need a new windscreen, I heartily recommend it. That's the place. But anyway, here he is in Fison Way near the windscreen place. And so the issue is that when he dies, late 59, early 60, what is going to happen to his kingdom that he has been able to preserve in this incredibly turbulent and conflicted political environment?
它看起来是个绝佳的地方。如果你在特特福德（Thetford），需要一块新的挡风玻璃，我衷心向你推荐。就是那个地方。不管怎样，他就在挡风玻璃修理厂附近的菲森威。所以问题是，当他在59年末60年初去世时，他在这个极其动荡和冲突的政治环境中得以保全的王国将会发生什么？
Is he going to get the Romans on board? Is that part of his plan? That is his plan. So Tacitus tells us what his plan is. He writes, Prosuticus, king of the Icani, famed for his long prosperity, had made the emperor, so that's Nero by this point, his heir, along with his two daughters, under the impression that this token of submission would put his kingdom and his house out of the reach of wrong.
他会把罗马人拉拢过来吗？那是他计划的一部分吗？那正是他的计划。所以塔西陀告诉我们他的计划是什么。他写道：“爱西尼人的国王普拉苏塔加斯以长期繁荣而闻名，他将皇帝——到这个时候就是尼禄（Nero）——连同他的两个女儿一起立为继承人，以为这种顺从的姿态会使他的王国和家族免受不法侵害。”
But the reverse was the result. And the reason for this is that Suetonius Paulinus, the governor, whose job it is essentially to kind of manage the politics of Britain, is away when Prasuticus dies. He's up in Wales, kind of attacking the Druids and so on. And the man on the spot is the procurator, who's basically the guy in charge of the finances. So he's kind of the chancellor of the Exchequer, a man called Catus Decianus. And it's his job to screw money out of the provincials. The province has to be made to pay for itself. And the problem with Britain is that it doesn't have the kind of urban infrastructure that lends itself to taxation in a way that, say, Greece or Egypt might do. And so he's constantly looking for ways to fill his treasure chests. And this is turbocharged by events actually in Rome, in the imperial capital,
但结果却恰恰相反。原因在于，总督苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯——其职责基本上是管理不列颠政治的人——在普拉苏塔加斯去世时不在场。他在威尔士北部，正忙着攻击德鲁伊等等。而当场的主管是财务官（procurator），基本上就是主管财政的人，所以他有点像财政大臣，一个名叫卡图斯·德西亚努斯（Catus Decianus）的男人。他的工作是从行省居民身上榨取金钱。必须让该行省实现自负盈亏。而不列颠的问题在于，它没有那种适合以希腊或埃及等国的方式进行征税的城市基础设施。因此，他不断寻找填满自己金库的方法。而这其实是被罗马帝国首都发生的事件火上浇油了，
because there Nero is thinking, do we really want Britain? It's a bit of a dump. There isn't really very much there. Should we withdraw? And one of Nero's leading advisors is the Stoic philosopher Seneca, who'd been his tutor. Seneca is obscenely rich and he's lent enormous amounts of money to all the various British chieftains and kings and aristocrats. That seems like a very strange, because how can he possibly be sure of getting it back? I think it's a bit like China kind of lending money to the Sri Lankan government to build a naval base. And then the Sri Lankan government defaults and they can just move in and grab it. I think it's a way of getting hold of territory from the natives. So Seneca alerted perhaps to the fact Nero is thinking of pulling out of Britain. He says, okay, I want my debts. And he sends in the
因为尼禄在那里思考：我们真的想要不列颠吗？这地方有点像个垃圾堆。那里其实没多少东西。我们应该撤军吗？尼禄的一位主要顾问是斯多葛学派哲学家塞内卡（Seneca），他曾是尼禄的导师。塞内卡富可敌国，他向不列颠的各个酋长、国王和贵族借出了巨额资金。这听起来很奇怪，因为他怎么可能确保能把钱收回来？我想这有点像中国借钱给斯里兰卡政府建造海军基地，然后斯里兰卡政府违约，他们就可以直接介入并把它据为己有。我认为这是一种从当地人手中夺取领土的方法。所以塞内卡大概察觉到尼禄正考虑撤出不列颠，便说：“好吧，我要收回我的债务。”于是他派出了
debt collectors. And presumably Presutagus is one of the people he's lent money to. And so it's a perfect storm. He dies, his will is ignored. And when Decianus, the procurator, sends in his heavies, they behave in a completely shameful manner. And again, to quote Tacitus, the kingdom of Prasuticus was plundered by centurions, his house by slaves, as if they were the spoils of war. First, his wife Boudica was scourged and his daughters outraged. All the chief men of the Icani, as if Rome had received the whole country as a gift, were stripped of their ancestral possessions and the king's relatives were made slaves. This, even by Roman standards, is absolute
催收人。据推测，普拉苏塔加斯就是他借过钱的人之一。因此，这是一场完美风暴。他死了，他的遗嘱被忽视了。当财务官德西亚努斯派遣他的打手时，他们的行为完全是无耻之尤。再次引用塔西陀的话：“普拉苏塔加斯的王国被百夫长掠夺，他的家被奴隶掠夺，就像战利品一样。首先，他的妻子布狄卡遭到鞭笞，他的女儿们受到强暴。爱西尼所有的主要贵族，就好像罗马把整个国家作为礼物接受了一样，都被剥夺了祖传财产，国王的亲戚也被沦为奴隶。”这，即使按照罗马的标准，也是绝对的
sacrilege. When you say sacrilege, it is sacrilege, right? If Boudicca is this, there she is on Fison Way and she has her sacral status, the oak gro Grove and stuff. And her daughters too. And her daughters too. And if you've basically sexually assaulted her daughters, that is a crime, not just against them as women, but against the gods, I'm guessing. Absolutely. And the thing that is really stupid about this is that it's happened while the massive Roman troops are in Wales and the nearest legionary bases are in Lincoln and in Exeter. So a long way away.
亵渎。当你说是亵渎时，这确实是亵渎，对吧？如果布狄卡是这样的人物——她身处菲森威，拥有神圣的地位、橡树林之类的东西。还有她的女儿们也是。还有她的女儿们也是。如果你基本上性侵了她的女儿们，这不仅是对她们作为女性的犯罪，也是对神明的犯罪，我猜。绝对是的。真正愚蠢的是，这一切发生的时候，罗马的主力部队正在威尔士，而最近的军团基地在林肯（Lincoln）和埃克塞特（Exeter）。所以离得非常非常远。
You know, it's basically, it's a mad, mad thing to have done. And although the speech that Dyer gives us and indeed his description of Boudicca is, I mean, it's a fabrication. Yeah. You know, he's writing century and more after the events happen. And the Romans love these stories about female supervillains, don't they? Cleopatra, the most obvious one, and Boudicca with massive hair and her flashing eyes. You say a villain. I mean, there is an understanding in that speech as to why she has rebelled that I think is probably accurate. That's the beauty, the nuance of Roman writing there, isn't it? That even
你知道，这基本上是一件疯狂透顶的事情。尽管狄奥留给我们的演讲以及他对布狄卡的描述——我的意思是，那是虚构的。是的。你知道的，他在事件发生一个多世纪后才写作。罗马人喜欢这种关于女性超级反派的故事，不是吗？克利奥帕特拉（Cleopatra）是最明显的例子，还有拥有一头长发和闪烁目光的布狄卡。你说反派。我的意思是，那篇演讲中对于她为何反抗的理解，我认为可能是准确的。这就是罗马写作的美妙之处、微妙之处，不是吗？即使
when they're writing about their opponents, they're able to get into their heads. Do you not think? Yes, I think so. And it's also clear that buddhica she who brings victory is absolutely taking the lead and the probability is dominate that this great massing of the ikani that cassius dia was describing in his passage that you read so beautifully may well have taken place um amid the car show rooms the car show rooms the concrete mixers of feis and way you and Way in this place that is kind of symbolic of the sacral dimension of Boudicca's rule. But the thing that makes it so threatening to the Romans is it's not just the Icani who are basically planning a war of liberation. There are the Trinovantes as well, because they effectively have been made slaves in their own country.
他们在写自己的对手时，也能够设身处地为他们着想。你不觉得吗？是的，我也这么觉得。而且显而易见，带来胜利的布狄卡绝对是在带头，多米尼克，很有可能——卡西乌斯·狄奥在你读得如此美妙的那段文字中所描述的爱西尼人的这种大规模集结——很可能就发生在菲森威的汽车展厅、
They were slaves to the Catecholonia, now they're slaves to the Romans. The focus for their loathing of Rome is Camulodunum, this colony of Roman veterans with its great monumental temple to a foreign autocrat. And so an alliance with the Trinovantes provides Boudicca with an enormous swelling of the armed forces at her beck and call. This is the peril that the Romans are now facing, that the Icanaean rebellion will incite other tribes to rise up against their rule, to proclaim their freedom all across Britain. The gods seem to be foretelling exactly such an eventuality. So in Camulodunum, it is said, even before news of the massing of the Icani, a statue of victory topples over.
混凝土搅拌机中间，在这个某种程度上象征着布狄卡统治神圣维度的地点。但让罗马人感到如此威胁的事情在于，不只是爱西尼人在策划一场解放战争。还有特里诺凡特人，因为他们实际上已经在自己的国家沦为奴隶了。他们曾经是卡塔沃洛尼人的奴隶，现在是罗马人的奴隶。他们对罗马痛恨的焦点是卡穆洛杜努姆，这个罗马退伍军人的殖民地，里面有一座献给外国独裁者的宏伟神庙。因此，与特里诺凡特人的联盟为布狄卡提供了言听计从的庞大武装力量。这就是罗马人现在面临的危机：爱西尼人的起义将煽动其他部落起来反抗他们的统治，在整个不列颠宣称他们的自由。诸神似乎在预示着这样一场事件的发生。所以在卡穆洛杜努姆，据说，甚至在爱西尼人集结的消息传来之前，一座胜利女神像就倒塌了。
Women are roused to a strange frenzy, foretelling the doom of the city. And on the Thames estuary, a ghostly town shimmers and appears in flames. The ocean turns to blood. And when the tide goes out, what seem to be human bodies are left on the beach. And none of these are promising omens. No, they're very disturbing portents, Tom. They are. And the Icani are on the march. And what these portents suggest is that it's not going to end well for Camulidunum. Crikey, what a cliffhanger. Can the Romans wrest back control of the situation? Or are there days in Britain numbered and is Boudicca set fair for victory?
妇女们陷入了一种奇怪的狂热中，预示着这座城市的厄运。在泰晤士河口（Thames estuary），一座幽灵般的城镇在火焰中隐约浮现。海洋变成了血红色。当退潮时，海滩上留下的似乎是人类的尸体。这些都不是什么好兆头。不，这些是非常令人不安的预兆，汤姆。确实如此。爱西尼人正在进军。这些预兆表明，卡穆洛杜努姆的结局不会好。天哪，真是个悬念啊！罗马人能重新夺回对局势的控制吗？还是他们在不列颠的日子屈指可数，而布狄卡注定要走向胜利？
Come back after the break and find out. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
中场休息后回来，一探究竟。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和现场门票的抢先体验，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Those final moments in the fetid, suffocating darkness, as the crammed hundreds waited for the bolts of the door to give way with the next reverberating blow, shaking the very foundations beneath, are beyond imagining. All hope was gone now. The pleas for assistance had gone out long days before,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。在那些恶臭、令人窒息的黑暗中的最后时刻，成百上千挤作一团的人等待着门栓在下一次震撼人心的撞击声中崩裂，这撞击震动了脚下的地基，这是无法想象的。所有的希望现在都破灭了。寻求援助的呼吁在许多天前就已经发出，
and for long days they had waited, and held the precinct, then the podium, and now the innermost sanctum of the temple. But no help had come, and they could hold no longer, for there was no one left to man the doorway. The able-bodied were dead, almost to the last. So that, Tom, is Echolands by Duncan Mackay, and he's describing the last moments of Camulodunum. Its defenders are besieged in the great temple of Claudius, outside the hordes of Icenae and Trinovantes, no doubt weapons in hand. Moustaches bristling. Yeah, moustaches bristling with bloodlust. What a terrible scene for anybody who's on the team Rome.
而且他们已经等待了许多天，坚守着神殿庭院，然后是高台，现在是神庙最内部的圣所。但救援没有到来，他们再也无法坚守了，因为已经没有活人来看守大门了。身强力壮的人几乎无一幸免，全死了。所以，汤姆，那是邓肯·麦凯的《回音之地》，他正在描述卡穆洛杜努姆最后的时刻。它的守卫者们被困在克劳狄乌斯的宏伟神庙中，外面是爱西尼人和特里诺凡特人的大军，毫无疑问他们手里都拿着武器。胡须根根竖起。是的，充满嗜血杀意的胡须根根竖起。对于任何站在罗马阵营的人来说，这是多么可怕的景象啊！
Roman civilization embattled and about to fall. Yes. And just to emphasize that Camulodonum, it's the place where 17 years before Caesar himself, the Emperor Claudius had come, maybe with his war elephants, to receive a kind of symbolic surrender of Britain. And ever since then, it's been consciously shaped as the great showcase capital of this new province. And the Temple of Claudius, it's by far the largest structure ever built in Britain. It's on an enormous scale. It has this huge kind of podium, this base, which is still there today in Colchester. And it's 80 by 105 feet. It has this huge kind of podium, this base, which is still there today in Colchester.
罗马文明腹背受敌，即将沦陷。是的。只需强调一点，卡穆洛杜努姆，就是17年前恺撒本人、克劳狄乌斯皇帝曾带着他的战象来到这里、接受不列颠某种象征性投降的地方。从那以后，它一直被刻意塑造成这个新行省宏伟的展示首都。克劳狄乌斯神庙是迄今为止不列颠建造的最大的建筑。它的规模极其宏大。它拥有巨大的高台——即基座，今天在科尔切斯特依然可以看到。它有80乘105英尺。它拥有巨大的高台——即基座，今天在科尔切斯特依然可以看到。
And it's 80 by 105 feet. It rises to a height of equivalent of a six-story building. Tacitus himself describes it as an arrogant stronghold of foreign rule. So you can imagine the impact that it has and that it's designed to have. The temple is also surrounded by all the kind of appurtenances that you would expect of a Roman colonia, a transplantation of Roman culture to foreign lands. So it's got baths, it's got an enormous theatre, it's got the great victory arch, all proclaiming the power and the might and the victory of Rome. And it's been settled there by veterans, people in the legions who've retired, who were given grants of land, given property, given a pension, and who in retirement almost certainly continue to display the kind of arrogance towards the defeated natives that is notoriously
它有80乘105英尺。它拔地而起，高度相当于一座六层楼的建筑。塔西陀本人将其描述为“外国统治的傲慢堡垒”。所以你可以想象它产生的影响以及它被设计出来所要产生的影响。这座神庙周围还环绕着你所期望的罗马殖民地的所有附属设施，这是罗马文化向外国土地的移植。所以它有浴场、有一个巨大的剧场、有宏伟的凯旋门，全都宣称着罗马的力量、威严和胜利。它由退伍军人殖民于此，也就是那些退役的军团士兵，他们被授予了土地、财产、养老金，而且在退休后几乎可以肯定，他们继续表现出对被击败的当地人的那种傲慢——这正是臭名昭著的
characteristic of legionaries. It's pretty awful, I think, if you are a native to be close to a legionary base. And it's pretty bad if you're in the neighborhood of a colony of veterans. So probably about maybe 15,000 people. And so surrounded by all this overwhelming architecture and all these veterans who are elderly now, but they can still handle a sword and shield, it must have seemed inconceivable to them that they could possibly face any threat from the defeated Britons, the Britunculi, the little Britons, kind of the contemptuous word that is used for them.
军团士兵的特征。如果你是一个当地人，住在军团基地附近，这大概相当糟糕。如果你在一个退伍军人殖民地的附近，那就更糟了。所以大概有15,000人左右。因此，被所有这些压倒性的建筑以及所有这些老去的退伍军人所包围——尽管他们年纪大了，但仍然挥得动剑和盾牌——在他们看来，他们怎么可能面对来自被击败的布立吞人（“布里通库利”[Britunculi]，这是用来称呼他们的带有蔑视意味的词，“小不列颠人”）的任何威胁，这简直是不可想象的。
But then, of course, the news comes in. First of all, you've got the ocean turning to blood, so that's bad. Cities of ghosts, ghostly cities. Yeah, terrifying. All of that, people kind of howling and screaming in the streets. And as the news comes in that the Icani are kind of sweeping towards them, the kind of horrific realisation that there's no military resources to hand. The procurator has about 200 men, but that's not much use. And there's no walls, right?
但随后，消息自然传来了。首先，你有了变成血红色的海洋，这可不妙。幽灵城市，幽灵般的城市。是的，太可怕了。所有那些人在街上嚎叫尖叫。随着消息传来，爱西尼人正朝他们席卷而来，人们产生了一种恐怖的意识：手头没有军事资源。财务官大约有200人，但那没什么用。而且这里没有城墙，对吧？
Camelodunum Colchester has no fortifications. There's no wall because again, it's a reflection of their self-confidence that they don't really need it. But having said that, I don't think the inhabitants despair. The veterans, as we've said, you know, they're perfectly able to stand and fight. And even though the city doesn't have walls, the Temple of Claudius does. So they can essentially retreat in there. They can encourage all the townspeople to bring their belongings, bring their valuables and cluster inside the temple wall. We know that some people hid their valuables because there was a famous find made in 2014 while they were digging up a shop in Colchester. And they found a box that contained silver bracelets and a kind of military armlet
科尔切斯特的卡默洛杜努姆没有防御工事。没有城墙，因为这再次反映了他们极度的自信，觉得自己根本不需要城墙。话虽如此，我认为居民们并未感到绝望。正如我们所说的那样，那些老兵完全有能力站出来战斗。而且即便这座城市没有城墙，克劳狄神庙却是有墙的。所以他们基本上可以撤退到神庙里去。他们可以鼓励城里的所有人带上自己的物品、带上贵重物品，聚集在神庙的墙内。我们知道有些人藏好了贵重物品，因为2014年在科尔切斯特挖掘一家店铺时，曾有一项轰动的考古发现。他们发现了一个箱子，里面装有银手镯、一种军事臂铠
and gold jewellery, so earrings and so on, which was clearly a veteran and his wife. And they'd hidden it away for safekeeping, never came back to claim it. And the expectation is that they will be able to hold out in the temple until armed relief comes, presumably from Lincoln or from one of the peripheral forts that surround the main legionary base, because that's the nearest supply of troops. But two things go wrong with this plan. And the first is that the legionary relief force doesn't arrive. And this isn't because of prevarication. The commander of the Ninth Legion, which is based in Lincoln, is a very bold and dashing commander, a man called Petilius Kerialis. And he sets out the
和黄金首饰，比如耳环等等，这显然属于一名老兵和他的妻子。他们把这些藏起来以求妥善保管，但再也没有回来取。人们的期望是，他们能够在神庙里坚守下去，直到武装救援到来，这援军想必来自林肯，或是来自环绕主要军团基地的那些外围堡垒，因为那是最近的军队补给源。但这个计划出了两个岔子。首先是军团救援部队根本没有抵达。这并不是因为对方在推诿。第九军团驻扎在林肯，其指挥官是一位非常大胆且勇猛的指挥官，名叫佩蒂留斯·塞里亚利斯。他一得到
moment that he's told of the desperate straits that the inhabitants of Colchester have found themselves in. But the problem is that he's marching at absolutely full speed, but he is still too late because back in Camulodunum, the Britons have proven unexpectedly determined in their attempts to force the temple. This is not what the Romans had been expected. The Britons have proven unexpectedly determined in their attempts to force the temple. This is not what the Romans had been expected. The Britons aren't proficient in the arts of kind of sieges. But this time they're so determined to storm it that they lay siege to the temple complex for two days. And then they clearly force their way up, probably up the steps of the temple podium.
科尔切斯特居民陷入绝境的消息，就立刻出发了。但问题是，尽管他以绝对的全速行军，却依然为时已晚，因为回到卡默洛杜努姆，不列颠人攻打神庙的决心超出了所有人的预期。这不是罗马人所料想的。不列颠人攻打神庙的决心超出了所有人的预期。这不是罗马人所料想的。不列颠人并不擅长围城战的技术。但这一次，他们决心一定要攻克神庙，因此对神庙建筑群展开了长达两天的围攻。随后他们显然硬闯了进去，很可能是顺着神庙高台的台阶冲上去的。
And eventually the veterans defending the temple are overwhelmed and all the non-competents, the women, the children, the injured, the old, who've been sheltering inside the temple are all massacred. So this is where your sympathies start to swing, right? Because the Britons have always been the underdogs up to this point. But now I think it's fair to say, Tom. They're not gentlemen. Yeah, they don't behave like gentlemen. That's very true. Yeah. So Tacitus specifies, and he finds're not gentlemen. Yeah, they don't behave like gentlemen. That's very true. Yeah. So Tacitus specifies, and he finds this surprising, that the Britons don't seem to be interested in taking prisoners, either for ransom or slavery, which is what the Romans would certainly do in that situation.
最终，保卫神庙的老兵们被压倒，所有避难于神庙内部的非战斗人员——妇女、儿童、伤员、老人——全都被大肆屠杀。所以，这时候你的同情心开始倾斜了，对吧？因为在此之前，不列颠人一直处于弱势。但现在我认为可以说，汤姆，他们可不是什么绅士。是的，他们的行为不像绅士。这非常真实。是的。所以塔西陀特别指出，并且他发现他们不是绅士。是的，他们的行为不像绅士。这非常真实。是的。所以塔西陀特别指出，并且他发现
Instead, he writes, their concern was only to slit throats, to set up gibbets, to burn, to crucify. And Dio gives really horrible details of what is supposed to have happened, particularly to high-ranking women who are taken. Whether the details are accurate, we don't know. Whether Dio is drawing on traditions that were authentically passed down to him. But it clearly bears witness to a perspective that the Romans did have that appalling atrocities had been committed. They're very unpleasant, but I'll read them because I think that this explains the violence of Roman retribution. So Dio writes, they hung up naked the noblest and most distinguished women and then cut off their
这令他惊奇的是，不列颠人似乎对抓捕俘虏毫无兴趣，无论是为了勒索赎金还是作为奴隶，而这正是罗马人在那种情况下肯定会做的事。相反，他写道，他们的关切仅仅是割喉、树起绞刑架、放火、钉十字架。迪奥对据称发生的事情给出了非常可怕的细节，尤其是对那些被抓的高贵女性。这些细节是否准确，我们不得而知。迪奥是否借鉴了真实流传给他的传统，我们也不知道。但这清楚地证明了罗马人确实持有的一种观点，即极其骇人听闻的暴行已经被犯下。它们非常令人不快，但我还是要读出来，因为我认为这解释了罗马人报复的暴力程度。于是迪奥写道，他们把最高贵、最杰出的妇女剥光衣服挂起来，然后割下她们的
breasts and sewed them to their mouths in order to make the women appear to be eating them. Afterwards, they impaled the women on sharp skewers, run lengthwise through the entire body. And having done that, they then put every kind of fragment of the Roman presence to the torch. And this is quite a challenge because most of the buildings, most of the houses in Camlodonum are built of a kind of sandy clay. So to actually burn it is quite an achievement, but it bears witness to the determination of the Britons, of the rebels, of the freedom fighters, however you want to call them, to absolutely eradicate all evidence of Rome's grandeur and to leave it a monument to the humiliation of the occupier. So it's smouldering, it's covered in corpses, and presumably, if Dio's account is true,
乳房，缝在她们的嘴上，好让这些妇女看起来像是在吃自己的乳房。随后，她们被尖锐的尖桩刺穿，尖桩从整个身体纵向贯穿。做完这些之后，他们便将罗马存在的各种碎片统统付之一炬。这可以说是相当大的挑战，因为卡默洛杜努姆的大多数建筑物、大多数房屋都是用一种沙质黏土建造的。所以能真正把它烧掉可以说是相当了不起的成就，但这证明了不列颠人、叛军、自由斗士——无论你怎么称呼他们——坚决要彻底根除罗马宏伟壮丽的一切痕迹，并将其化为占领者奇耻大辱的纪念碑的决心。因此，它还在冒烟，到处都是尸体，而且想必，如果迪奥的记述属实，
there are spectacles of humiliation in death of the kind that the Romans themselves, with their love of crucifixion, would entirely have understood and seen as something monstrous and appalling. So this is a pretty ghastly spectacle. Now what's happened to Petilius Kerialis? He is marching south. You said he was very bold and swashbuckling. He's marching south from Lincoln. Headstrong, one might almost say, because he marches straight into an ambush. So the Icani and the Trinifantes have destroyed Camledon and they then swing round to set an ambush for Kerialis, who walks straight into it. His legionaries are wiped out. He, in command of the cavalry, is able to withdraw just and to retreat. But even that is a very close-run thing. So they've lost the Colonia, a legion has been
还会出现这种死亡时的羞辱奇观，罗马人自己由于酷爱钉十字架，会完全理解这一点，并将其视为一种极其怪异和骇人听闻的事情。所以这是一个相当可怕的奇观。那么佩蒂留斯·塞里亚利斯怎么样了？他正在向南行军。你刚才说他非常大胆、风流倜傥。他正从林肯向南行军。可以说是刚愎自用，因为他直直地走进了伏杀圈。因此，爱西尼人和特里诺万特人摧毁了卡默洛杜努姆，然后调转枪头去伏击塞里亚利斯，而他直接走了进去。他的军团士兵被全歼了。作为骑兵指挥官的他，仅仅能够撤退保全自己。但即便如此，也是一场极其险恶的恶战。所以他们失去了殖民地，一个军团遭到了
badly mauled. And so it's unsurprising at this point that the procurator, Cattius Decianus, assumes that the province is lost and flees Britain for Gaul. Meanwhile, as we described in yesterday's episode, Suetonius Paulinus has been putting the groves of the Druids in Anglesey to the torch. And that is where he is when news comes to him of what is happening down in the southeast. So he has no time to enjoy his victory. He immediately orders his men to prepare to march from Anglesey down Watling Street to the southeast. He has troops from two legions, the 14th and the 20th. He also sends orders to a man called Poinius Posthumus, who's the commander of the Second
惨重的打击。因此，在这个时候，财政官卡蒂乌斯·德奇亚努斯认为该省已经失守，并从不列颠逃往高尔，也就不足为奇了。与此同时，正如我们在昨天的节目中所描述的那样，苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯一直在安格尔西岛纵火焚烧德鲁伊的树林。当东南部发生的事情的消息传到他那里时，他正身处那里。所以他根本没有时间享受他的胜利。他立即命令部下准备从安格尔西岛沿沃特灵街向东南方向行军。他拥有来自两个军团的军队，即第十四军团和第二十军团。他还向一个名叫波伊尼乌斯·波斯图穆斯的人下达了命令，后者是埃克塞特的第二
Legion in Exeter, to set out. So essentially, it's a mass muster of all the legionary forces in the province. And the likelihood is, although neither Tacitus nor Dio actually specify this, that Suetonius Paulinus, with his cavalry, advances ahead of his infantry down Watling Street, essentially because he doesn't know what's going on. He needs intelligence. He needs to find out what is Boudicca up to? Is she threatening to attack other cities? And so gallops down Watling Street. Just a quick question, Tom. Galloping down Watling Street, the Romans have been there
军团的指挥官，命令他出发。所以从本质上讲，这是该省所有军团力量的一次大规模集结。很有可能的是，尽管塔西陀和迪奥都没有明确说明这一点，但苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯带着他的骑兵，走在了步兵的前面，沿沃特灵街向前推进，这主要是因为他不知道发生了什么。他需要情报。他需要弄清楚布狄卡在搞什么鬼？她是否在威胁要攻击其他城市？于是他策马沿着沃特灵街飞奔。汤姆，我有一个简单的问题。在沃特灵街上策马飞奔，罗马人在那里
17 years. So in that time, they have built roads. Again, these are kind of old trackways that the Romans are starting to upgrade. So, you know, 50 mile speed limits on the motorway, that kind of thing. They're in the process of upgrading it. I mean, definitely it's more traversable now than it would have been 20 years before. And so he's able to get to London before Boudicca. And London, unlike Camaldonum, unlike Beryllium, is distinctive because there hadn't, as far as we know, been any site there before. It hadn't been a kind of major tribal meeting centre. And the reason why it's grown is very obvious. It's because it's the lowest bridging point on the Thames and the Romans have built a bridge over it, but it's also navigable. So ships coming from the continent can come. And it probably began
已经17年了。所以在那个时期，他们修建了道路。同样，这些也是罗马人开始升级改造的旧土路。所以呢，这就像高速公路上的50英里限速那种情况。他们正在对其进行升级改造。我的意思是，毫无疑问，现在的通行条件比20年主要好得多了。因此，他得以在布狄卡之前抵达伦敦。伦敦与卡默洛杜努姆不同，与贝鲁姆不同，它的独特之处在于，据我们所知，以前那里没有任何定居点。它并非某种主要的部族会聚中心。它之所以发展起来，原因非常明显。因为它是泰晤士河上最低的桥梁点，罗马人在上面建造了一座桥，但它也是可以通航的。所以来自欧洲大陆的船只可以开过来。它可能最初是
as a military base, but it's so suited for trade. So Tacitus specifies what had been fueling its growth. He said London was teeming with merchants and merchant shipping. And we have amazing evidence for this from these, they're called the Bloomberg tablets. Bloomberg have this great kind of centre off the Walbrook, which was the river that flowed down into the Thames that London was originally built around. And so the watery character of the soil preserved organic material and enabled these writing tablets to be preserved. And we have the earliest one comes from the very first decade of Roman rule, and it points to it already becoming this great commercial hub.
作为军事基地起步的，但它太适合贸易了。因此，塔西陀详细说明了推动其发展的因素。他说，伦敦到处都是商人和商船。我们从这些被称为“彭博泥板”的文物中找到了惊人的证据。彭博公司在瓦尔布鲁克河附近有一个很棒的中心，这条河曾经流入泰晤士河，伦敦最初就是围绕它建立的。因此，土壤的水性特征保存了有机材料，并使这些写字板得以保存。我们发现最早的一块来自罗马统治的第一个十年，它表明伦敦已经开始成为这样一个巨大的商业枢纽。
In fact, it points to it being a place where if you're going to do business, you need to wear the proper business attire. So it's a kind of foreshadowing of the suit. So it says they're boasting throughout the whole market that you have lent them money. Therefore, I ask you in your own interest not to appear shabby. So dress up and look smart. And then there's another one. It's the first dated document in the whole of British history, dates from the 8th of January,
事实上，它表明这里是一个如果你想做生意就必须穿着得体的地方。所以这有点像是西装的先兆。上面写着，你们在整个市场上吹嘘说你们借给他们钱了。因此，为了你们自己的利益，我请求你们不要显得寒酸。所以要盛装打扮，看起来精明一点。然后还有另一块。这是整个不列颠历史上第一份有确切日期的文件，可以追溯到公元58年
AD 58, and it's an IOU. So 12 documents in all from before AD 60. And it shows that London is already, it's literate and it's mercantile, probably about 10,000 people. It's kind of got a Wild West quality. It's a boom town. It's cosmopolitan. It's got's kind of got a wild west quality it's a boom town it's cosmopolitan it's got this kind of mix of roman and native architectural styles you've got docks full of ships but dominic as with camelidonum no walls so sitting duck absolutely sitting down particularly if saturnus polinus has come without his legions only with cavalry there's no prospect of holding the town and so he orders a mass evacuation. The Londoners have three options, I guess. They can withdraw with Paulinus
1月8日，这是一张借据。在公元60年之前的所有文件总共有12份。它表明伦敦当时就已经具备识字能力和商业气息了，大约有1万人口。它有点像美国西部荒野的风格。这是一个繁荣的城镇。它具有大都会的气息。它拥有这种罗马本土建筑风格与当地建筑风格的融合。你拥有装满船只的码头，但是多米尼克，就像卡默洛杜努姆一样，没有城墙。所以这是一只待宰的羔羊，绝对是待宰的羔羊，特别是如果苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯来的时候没有带着他的军团，只有骑兵的话，就完全没有坚守这座城镇的可能，因此他下令进行大规模疏散。伦敦人大概有三个选择。他们可以跟保利纳斯
himself, or they can cross the Thames. And again, presumably London Bridge will be pulled down to stop the Icani and the Trinovantes from crossing the river. Or of course, if they have access to ships, they can get into the ships and go out into the waters because the Iacani will not have ships. Of course, there are some, I guess those who are infirm or those who don't have the packaged animals to take their goods with them, who think, oh, well, she may not come. Maybe all right, but it isn't all right. Boudicca does come. And there is all kinds of archaeological evidence for what then happens, perhaps most strikingly in the foundations of what is now number one poultry, which is perhaps most strikingly in the foundations of
本人一起撤退，或者他们可以穿过泰晤士河。同样，想必伦敦桥会被拆毁，以阻止爱西尼人和特里诺万特人过河。当然，如果他们有船只的话，他们可以登上船只，驶向水域，因为爱西尼人是没有船的。当然，我猜其中有些人，比如那些体弱多病的人，或者那些没有打包的牲口来带走财物的人，会想，噢，好吧，她可能不会来。也许一切都会好起来的，但并没有好起来。布狄卡确实来了。随之而来的是各种各样的考古证据，证明了接下来发生的事情，或许最令人震惊的是现在被称为“1号家禽街”的建筑地基，或许最令人震惊的是现在被称为“1号家禽街”的建筑地基，
what is now number one poultry, which is by Bank Tube Station in the heart of the city of London now. And it was an office block that was designed by James Sterling and built in the 90s. And before it was built, archaeologists went down into the depths and they found this layer of fire. And there was evidence of kind of blackened timbers and burned pottery and petrified mud brick and this is evidence for the first great fire of london the city is again as camlodonum had been burned by buddhica yeah yeah obliterated so you can imagine that in verillanium which is kind of 20 miles 25 miles st auburn'sans. Right. St. Albans, as it's called now. The inhabitants there would have seen smoke rising from London as it burnt and would have known what was coming. And of course, unlike London,
它位于如今伦敦市中心的银行地铁站旁。那是一栋由詹姆斯·斯特灵设计并于90年代建造的办公大楼。在它建造之前，考古学家深入地下，发现了这一层火灾痕迹。有烧焦的木材、烧毁的陶器以及石化的泥砖的证据，这些都是伦敦第一场大火的证据。这座城市再次像卡默洛杜努姆一样，被布狄卡付之一炬。是的，是的，彻底被毁。所以你可以想象，在维鲁兰姆，也就是大约20英里、25英里外的圣奥尔本斯。没错。正如现在所称的圣奥尔本斯。那里的居民一定眼睁睁地看着伦敦燃烧时升起的浓烟，并且会知道接下来会发生什么。当然，与伦敦不同，
Berlinium has been built as a Kivitas, as a kind of a Roman foundation on a tribal center. And it's the capital of the Catephaloni, who are the enemies of the Trinovantes. And so it's a reminder, I think, that Boudicca is not just fighting a war for freedom from the Romans, but she is also engaged in an intra-tribal war of the kind that had been convulsing southeastern Britain for decades and decades and decades. So this is the parallel we were talking about last time with the war in what's now Mexico. There are existing rivalries that are actually being ramped up, amplified by the arrival of a colonizing outsider. Yes, exactly. And so in Verulamium, everyone knows that she'll be coming for them, particularly the Trinovantes will be coming for them. And Suetonius Paulinus still at this point,
维鲁兰姆被建为一个“西维塔斯”（Civitas），作为建立在部族中心之上的罗马殖民地。它是卡蒂维劳尼人的首都，而这些人是特里诺万特人的敌人。因此，我认为这提醒了人们，布狄卡不仅在为摆脱罗马人的自由而战，她还卷入了一场部族内战，这种内战几十年来一直在蹂躏着不列颠东南部。所以这就是我们上次谈到的与现在墨西哥战争的相似之处。现有的敌对状态实际上正在被殖民地外来者的到来所加剧、放大。是的，完全正确。所以在维鲁兰姆，每个人都知道她会冲着他们来，尤其是特里诺万特人会冲着他们来。而苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯此时此刻，
presumably hasn't joined his legions. And so again, he has no choice but to evacuate the city. And again, Verulamium is put to the torch. So that's the third city that's been incinerated by Boudicca and her forces. And this is obviously a moment of incredible peril for the governor, but also for the entire future of Roman rule in Britain. Because by withdrawing from Verulanium in particular, this is a city that is emblematic of the perks that you get for collaborating with Rome. And the fact that the Romans have been unable to defend the Catephalonian capital is potentially fatal to the entire system of alliances that the Romans have built up. Because the Catephaloni, and also Togedubnus to the south in his kingdom,
大概还没有与他的军团汇合。所以同样，他别无选择，只能疏散这座城市。维鲁兰姆再次被付之一炬。所以这是第三座被布狄卡和她的军队焚为灰烬的城市。对于总督以及不列颠罗马统治的整个未来来说，这显然是一个极其危急的时刻。因为通过从维鲁兰姆撤退，这座城市象征着与罗马合作所能获得的好处。罗马人无力保卫卡蒂维劳尼人首都这一事实，对罗马人建立的整个同盟体系构成了潜在的致命打击。因为卡蒂维劳尼人，以及南方的国王托古杜布努斯，
they must by this point be kind of weighing up the odds and trying to decide which horse to back. Yeah. Why would you stick with a colonizer who can't even defend its own cities? Yeah. That means that Sotonius Paulinus, essentially, he needs to force a battle very, very soon. Because if he doesn't, the whole infrastructure of Roman Britain is going to fall to pieces. And the other reason why he wants to force a battle, I think very soon, is because there is always a risk that Boudicca's forces may split up and start separating. And then it becomes obviously much harder to wipe out the entire force in a single go, which again, may remind listeners of the episodes that we did on Custer, where it was constantly the ambition
他们此刻一定在权衡利弊，试图决定押注哪一方。是的。你为什么要死守一个连自己城市都保护不了的殖民者呢？是的。这意味着苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯基本上需要非常非常快地发动一场战役。因为如果不这样做，罗马不列颠的整个基础设施都将土崩瓦解。我认为他希望尽快发动战役的另一个原因是，始终存在着一种风险，即布狄卡的军队可能会分兵并开始分散。这样一来，想要一举消灭整支部队显然就会困难得多，这再次会让听众回想起我们关于卡斯特尔的节目，当时第七骑兵队一直以来的野心就是
of the 7th Cavalry to find their enemy in a single place and then go in. And this kind of leads to the Battle of Bighorn. Anyway, in the context of Britain, there are two theories about what happens next. The first is that Suetonius Paulinus has to retreat back up Watling Street to rendezvous with his men who still haven't arrived and joined him. And he retreats and retreats and retreats until he meets with his infantry coming down. There's still no sign of the second legion coming from Exeter. They haven't arrived, but he decides, whatever, you know, I
在同一个地方找到敌人然后发起进攻。而这最终导致了小大角战役。无论如何，在不列颠的背景下，关于接下来发生的事情有两种理论。第一种是苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯不得不沿着沃特灵街撤退回去，与那些仍未抵达并与他汇合的部下会合。他不断地撤退、撤退、撤退，直到遇到南下增援的步兵。仍然没有来自埃克塞特的第二军团的迹象。他们还没有到达，但他决定，不管怎样，你知道的，
can't afford to wait for them. He's massively outnumbered, but he decides to make a stand against Boudicca's army, which has been on this theory, pursuing him up Watling Street. And Tacitus gives a description. He says he chose a position in a defile with a wood at his rear. I mean, that's very vague, but there may be an element of precision to it because Tacitus, as we said in the previous episode, is the son-in-law of Agricola, who is a man who is serving on Suetonius Paulinus' staff. Yeah. So it must be a pretty well-informed witness. Yeah. It's in a defile.
他已经等不起了。尽管他的兵力处于绝对劣势，但他还是决定迎战布狄卡的大军，根据这一理论，这支军队一直在沃特灵街上追击他。塔西陀做出了描述。他说他选择了一个峡谷中的阵地，背后是一片树林。我的意思是，这非常模糊，但其中可能包含某种精确性，因为正如我们在上一期节目中所说的那样，塔西陀是阿格里科拉的女婿，而阿格里科拉曾在苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯的参谋部服役。是的。所以这一定是一个消息灵通的目击者。是的。它在一个峡谷里。
There's a wood at the back. It means that they can't be outflanked. So slight kind of Agincourt quality to it. And his army proves way too professional for the Britons. Because, you know, to pursue your Custer parallel, Boudicca's army is obviously not a professional, well-organized army like the Roman army. I mean, it's much more of a horde, but it's actually not just even just men, is it? It's probably women and children. Yes. So it's more like the big villages of the Lakota. Yes. I think that's a really good analogy. It's an entire people on the march. So they have wagons and oxen and all kinds of things. It's kind of on a biblical scale. And so that's why this battle is so important to the Romans, because it gives them a chance
背面有一片树林。这意味着他们不会被包抄。所以这有点阿让库尔战役的特质。他的军队证明了其专业程度远超不列颠人。因为，你知道的，延续你的卡斯特尔类比，布狄卡的军队显然不是像罗马军队那样专业、组织严密的军队。我的意思是，它更像是一群乌合之众，但实际上不仅仅是男人，对吧？可能还有妇女和儿童。是的。所以它更像是达科他人的大型村落。是的。我认为这是一个非常好的类比。这是一个在行进中的整个民族。所以他们有大车、有公牛以及各种各样的东西。这有点像是圣经规模的。这就是为什么这场战役对罗马人如此重要，因为它给了他们一个机会
to exact a kind of genocidal revenge. And essentially, Roman military training, we talked earlier about how do the Britons fight. The Britons fight by charging. And if that first charge can be blocked, then essentially they're doomed. And all of Roman military training is about ensuring that the line of the legions can hold, psychologically, but also in terms of kit, equipment, armour, whatever. So the legions start moving forwards. They have the gladius,
去实施某种灭绝种族的复仇。本质上，罗马军事训练——我们之前讨论过不列颠人是如何战斗的。不列颠人是通过冲锋来战斗的。如果第一次冲锋能够被挡住，那么他们基本上就注定要失败了。而罗马所有的军事训练都是为了确保军团的阵线能够稳固，无论是在心理上，还是在装备、防具等方面。于是军团开始向前推进。他们装备了短剑，
the stabbing sword, which is designed to eviscerate, to slit open the stomach. And most of the Britons, they don't have body armour. So very, very rapidly, the battleground becomes a great sea of kind of viscera and blood, and they're wading through it. The Britons are wiped out. The men, the women, the children, the wagons are burnt. Effectively, as I say, this is pointedly genocidal. It's slaughtered on an enormous scale. And the question then is, well, where is it fought?
这是一种旨在开膛破肚、割开胃部的刺杀剑。大多数不列颠人都没有身穿防具。所以非常非常快地，战场变成了一片内脏和鲜血的汪洋大海，他们涉血前行。不列颠人被全歼了。男人、女人、儿童、马车都被烧毁。实际上，正如我所说，这是带有针对性的种族灭绝。这是一场规模巨大的屠杀。那么问题来了，这场战役究竟是在哪里打响的呢？
So the favourite candidate is a place called Mansetta in the Midlands, about 75 miles up Watling Street from Verilanium. But there is an alternative theory which Duncan McKay in his book Echolands has proposed, and which, because it's the most recent book on Boudicca I've read, I'm completely convinced by. Dominic, our listeners will know that our ability to work out military positionings isn't always all it could be. It's been for yourself, Tom. Shocking. I think Mackay's arguments are, I find them very convincing. And he argues that actually, it's Verilanium that is where the rendezvous between Suetonius Paulinus and his cavalry
因此，最受青睐的候选地点是中部地区的曼赛塔，距离维鲁兰姆沿沃特灵街约75英里。但还有另一种理论，由邓肯·麦凯在其著作《回声之地》中提出，由于这是我读过的关于布狄卡的最新著作，我完全被它说服了。多米尼克，我们的听众会知道，我们确定军事阵地的能力并不总是尽如人意。你自己也是这样，汤姆。太惊人了。我认为麦凯的论点，我发现它们非常有说服力。他认为实际上，维鲁兰姆才是苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯与他的骑兵
and the infantry happen. He can't afford to keep retreating for the reasons that we've given. And more than that, he asked the obvious question, which I've never, you know, in the various accounts of Boudicca, I've never heard asked before, which is why would Boudicca pursue him? She's got the harvest coming. She doesn't want to go off herring around Britain. You know, she's done what she set out to do. She wanted to inflict humiliation on her two great enemies, on the Romans and on the Cativalurnae. She's done that. She's got enormous amounts of loot. And I will read what Mackay said. The lure of Camulodonum, Landinium, Verulanium, and the scent of Paulinus had kept the vast tribal confederation together, and it had proved itself the equal of the Ninth Legion under Kerialis.
以及步兵会合的地点。出于我们已经给出的原因，他承担不起继续撤退的代价。不仅如此，他还提出了一个显而易见的问题，在关于布狄卡的各种记载中，我以前从未听人问过这个问题，那就是布狄卡为什么要追击他？她有收获季节要忙。她不想在不列颠到处瞎转悠。你知道的，她已经完成了她着手要做的事。她想要给她的两个大敌人——罗马人和卡蒂维劳尼人——施加羞辱。她做到了。她得到了大量的战利品。我来读一下麦凯说的话。卡默洛杜努姆、伦敦、维鲁兰姆的诱惑，以及保利纳斯的气味，将庞大的部族联盟凝聚在了一起，事实证明它与塞里亚利斯的第九军团不相上下。
It was still willing and able to fight, but that resolve must have been fast dissolving as the ancient road home along the Icknield Way, the Icaney Way, came within the orbit of the hungry scouts and desperate foraging parties. They were farmers, and this was the blessed trackway back to their farms. So Verulanium is the point where the Icknield Way and Watling Street meet. And the likelihood is, McKay argues, seotonius paulinus occupies that meeting point because he doesn't want the icani to disperse he needs this victory and he pinpoints a place called windridge farm which is north of what is now saint alban's apparently there's a road and things i haven't been to it but i'm certainly going to go and look at it after recording this episode of course topographically. Topographically, it matches Tacitus' description.
它仍然愿意并且能够战斗，但随着通往家园的古老道路——伊克尼尔德路（The Icknield Way）、爱西尼路（Icaney Way）——进入饥饿的侦探和绝望的觅食小队的范围，这种决心一定在迅速消融。他们是农民，这是通往他们农场的受祝福的小路。所以维鲁兰姆是伊克尼尔德路与沃特灵街交汇的点。麦凯辩称，很有可能苏埃托尼乌斯·保利纳斯占领了那个交汇点，因为他不想让爱西尼人分散，他需要这场胜利，他精确锁定了温里奇农场这个地方，它位于现在圣奥尔本斯以北。显然那里有一条路和一些东西，我没去过，但我录完这一期节目后肯定要去看看。当然，从地形上看。
It's strategically placed on these two great roads. And intriguingly, over 60 lead slingshots, apparently, of a kind used by the Romans have been found there. So it's definitely the site of a battle. Okay. I mean, why not? Yeah, why not? Are you convinced? I think the evidence of the 60 slingshots, you'd need to show me an alternative battle
从地形上看，它符合塔西陀的描述。它在战略上位于这两条大道路上。有趣的是，据报道，在那里发现了60多枚罗马人使用的那种铅弹弓弹。所以这绝对是一个战场的遗址。好吧。我的意思是，为什么不呢？是的，为什么不呢？你被说服了吗？我认为60枚弹弓弹的证据，你得向我展示一个替代的战场，
that could have taken place there for me not to believe that this is a plausible contender. Certainty is impossible, as we have had to say repeatedly over the course of these episodes. But you know what? In a way, I know this is a controversial thing to say. I mean, does it matter? Who cares where it actually, because we know what the result was. The result is what matters. The result matters. And, you know, it's often said that Towton in the Wars of the Roses is the bloodiest battle ever fought on English soil.
它可能曾发生在那里，否则我无法相信这是一个合理的候选地点。正如我们在这些节目中不得不反复说的那样，确定性是不可能的。但你知道吗？从某种程度上来说，我知道说这话会有争议。我的意思是，这重要吗？谁在乎它实际发生在哪里，因为我们知道结果是什么。结果才是最重要的。结果很重要。而且，你知道，人们常说玫瑰战争中的陶顿战役是英格兰土地上发生过的最血腥的战役。
But I think this must be bloodier. So McKay convincingly argues that maybe 40,000 Britons lost their lives there. That many? She would have had that many people, you know, had Custer won the Battle of the Little Bighorn and slaughtered all the Native Americans who were there, the women and the children as well, it would have been enormous slaughter. And this is exactly what the Romans are setting out to do. They have basically the mass of two peoples, the Icania and the Trinovantes, and they can do what they want with them. And that battle, that slaughter, that massacre, is then followed up by further slaughter and devastation because the Romans are shaken, they feel humiliated, but clearly they are also out for revenge because they've been to Camulodonum
但我认为这场战役一定更血腥。所以麦凯令人信服地辩称，可能有多达4万名不列颠人在那里失去了生命。有那么多？她会有那么多人，你知道的，如果卡斯特尔赢得了小大角战役，并屠杀了当时所有的美洲原住民，包括妇女和儿童，那也将是一场巨大的屠杀。这正是罗马人着手要做的事情。他们基本上掌握了两个民族的庞大群体，即爱西尼人和特里诺万特人，他们可以对他们为所欲为。那场战役、那场屠杀、那场大屠杀之后，伴随着更多的屠杀和毁灭，因为罗马人受到了震撼，他们感到受到羞辱，但显然他们也是为了复仇，因为他们去过卡默洛杜努姆，
and they see what has been wrought there. And it seems that not only are people slaughtered, but almost everything that made the Icane distinctive is targeted. So that great artificial oak and glade is systematically destroyed, which is obviously good news for car manufacturers, but not good news for the sacral dimension of Icaneean kingship. And of course, there is no kingship because from this point on, all of East Anglia is formally absorbed under Roman rule. And actually, there are so many reprisals, they're so bloody that eventually they become too much even for the Romans. And in 61, Paulinus is replaced as governor, but he does go back. He saved Britain. He has a very distinguished career,
他们看到了那里所犯下的罪恶。似乎不仅人们遭到屠杀，而且几乎所有使爱西尼人具有独特性的东西都成为了攻击目标。那棵巨大的、由人工做成的橡树和林地被系统性地摧毁了，这显然对汽车制造商是个好消息，但对爱西尼国王神圣性的维度来说却不是好消息。当然，这里不再有王权，因为从这一刻起，东安格利亚的全部地区都被正式并入罗马统治之下。事实上，报复是如此之多，以至于血腥到最后甚至让罗马人都觉得过头了。在61年，保利纳斯被免去了总督职务，但他确实回去了。他拯救了不列颠。他有着非常杰出的职业生涯，
ends up embroiled in the civil wars in 69 when there were four emperors. And he has essentially a better retirement than poor Poinius Posthumus in Exeter, who never came. And whether he didn't receive his orders or whether he ignored them or whether he was unable to answer them, didn't matter. He'd brought disgrace on his legion and so he commits suicide. So we've just done a series on Evita, and of course her afterlife is almost as fascinating as her life. And people may be wondering what happens to Boudicca. I think it's Dio who says that she is buried sumptuously by her people. I don't quite know how they'd have been able to do that if they'd all been slaughtered. Tacitus says that she poisoned herself. But obviously she's such a totemic, charismatic
最终卷入了69年有四位皇帝的内战中。他的晚年生活基本上比埃克塞特那个从未到来的可怜的波伊尼乌斯·波斯图穆斯要好。无论他是没有收到命令、还是无视了命令、亦或是无法回复命令，这都不重要了。他给自己的军团带来了耻辱，所以他自杀了。我们刚刚做了一个关于艾薇塔的系列节目，当然，她身后的名气几乎和她的人生一样引人入胜。人们可能会好奇布狄卡遭遇了什么。我想是迪奥说她被自己的人民风光大葬了。我不太清楚如果他们都被屠杀了，他们怎么能做到这一点。塔西陀则说她服毒自尽了。但显而易见，她是如此具有图腾色彩、充满个人魅力的
figure that people have always wondered where was she buried? So as early as 1624, there was an antiquarian called Edmund Bolton who suggested that she'd been buried at Stonehenge, which had been raised as her tomb. That was his theory. I like that theory. Yeah. 1879, workmen were found three tombs outside a village in gloucestershire called bird lip great name and this has been dated to the middle of the first century a.d and the central grave was the skeleton of a woman with sumptuous grave goods but again you have to wonder you know what was she doing gloucestershire it's a long way yeah it's the wrong side of the country but the best theory which was proposed in 1937 by a former editor of the Scotsman called Lewis
人们一直很好奇她究竟被埋葬在哪里？早在1624年，就有一位名叫埃德蒙·博尔顿的古董收藏家提出，她被埋葬在巨石阵，巨石阵被当成了她的陵墓。这就是他的理论。我喜欢这个理论。是的。1879年，工人们在格洛斯特郡一个名叫伯德利普的村庄外面发现了三座古墓，这个名字真不错，经考证这些古墓建于公元一世纪中期，中间的墓穴里是一位女性的骨骼，里面有奢华的随葬品。但话说回来，你不得不纳闷，她怎么会跑到格洛斯特郡去呢？那地方可真够远的。是的，那是在国家的那一侧，方向不对。不过，在1937年由《苏格兰人报》前主编路易斯提出过一个最好的理论
Spence, is that she was buried in the vicinity of King's Cross railway station in London. And he based this theory on earlier and erroneous speculation that the remains of an elephant that had been found in the site had been a Roman elephant. In fact, it was Paleolithic. And Barnsbury, which is, you know, it's the area of London by King's Cross, that this had been a Roman camp again. It hadn't been, but it didn't stop this theory from taking wings. And in the Second World War, people start saying she'd actually been buried under a platform in King's Cross. And by the 1970s, this had been narrowed down to platform 10 which of course is the platform that trains to Cambridge go to so literally she buried just a quarter of a platform away from the train to Hogwarts yes so JK Rowling was actually asked had she been influenced in that by the stories of Boudicca being buried at platform 10 and she said no but I like to think that you know
斯彭斯提出的，即她被埋葬在伦敦国王十字火车站附近。他提出这一理论的依据是早期的一项错误推测，即在该遗址发现的一头大象的遗骸是一头罗马大象。事实上，那是旧石器时代的。而巴恩斯伯里，也就是国王十字车站附近的伦敦地区，这曾经是一个罗马军营。它其实并不是，但这并没有阻止这个理论插上翅膀。在第二次世界大战期间，人们开始说她实际上是被埋在国王十字车站的一个站台下面。到了20世纪70年代，这个范围被缩小到了第10站台，
I mean maybe it was at the back of her mind and i think that that does bear witness to the fact that buddhica remains a kind of culture hero you know she's still capable of generating these kind of urban myths i mean she's a fascinating figure even though we know so little and she's pretty scary but she's the first great character in british history isn't she i mean we had keraticus before but, with the hair and the golden talk and that great address. I mean, I know Cassius Dio is making it up, but she is the first person about whom it's possible to really weave a story with sort of a slight trace elements of personality, do you think?
人物，以至于人们总是好奇：她到底被埋在哪里？早在1624年，就有一位名叫埃德蒙·博尔顿的古物研究者提出，她被埋葬在巨石阵，巨石阵是被作为她的陵墓升起来的。这就是他的理论。我喜欢这个理论。是的。1879年，工人们在格洛斯特郡一个名叫伯德利普的村庄外发现了三座陵墓——这名字真好听——这可以追溯到公元一世纪中叶，中央墓穴是一名女性的骨骼，陪葬品极其奢华。但同样你不得不感到好奇，你知道的，她在格洛斯特郡在干什么？那可太远了。是的，那是国家的另一边。不过，最好的理论是1937年由《苏格兰人报》前主编路易斯·
You know, you impersonated her as Mrs. Thatcher. And I remember loads of cartoons showing Mrs. Thatcher as Boudicca, kind of rushing around in a chariot and all that kind of thing. Yeah, that's why I did it. It's one of those stories from British history that pretty much everyone does know. Yeah, they know the name, even if they don't know the details of the story, don't they? Fascinating, Tom. A wonderful story and wonderfully told.
你知道，你曾模仿过她饰演撒切尔夫人。我记得有很多漫画把撒切尔夫人画成布狄卡，乘着战车到处冲杀之类的。是的，这就是我模仿的原因。这是英国历史中几乎人尽皆知的故事之一。是的，哪怕不知道故事细节，大家都知道这个名字，对吧？太迷人了，汤姆。一个精彩的故事，讲述得也很棒。
But not the end of our Roman Britain series, because, of course, there was still much of Britain left to conquer. And in the next episode, we will be turning to somebody who really caught my imagination when I was a boy, reading the Lady Bird books about Roman Britain, and that was Agricola and the story of his great adventures as he headed north. So if you remember the Restless History Club,
但这并不是我们罗马不列颠系列的终结，因为当然，不列颠还有很大一部分尚未被征服。在下一集中，我们将把目光投向某个人，当我还是个男孩、读着关于罗马不列颠的“瓢虫书”时，他深深地激发了我的想象力，那就是阿格里科拉，以及他向北进发时的伟大冒险故事。所以，如果你是“历史俱乐部”的会员，
you can hear that right away. If you are, however, a member of the freedom-loving iKenny, or whatever you call it, I-C-N-I as I called them when I was a boy, then you just have to wait till Thursday. More for you. And that bombshell. Thank you very much, Tom. Goodbye.
你可以马上收听。不过，如果你是热爱自由的爱西尼人（iKenny）的成员，或者无论你管他们叫什么，正如我小时候所叫的I-C-N-I那样，那么你只需等到周四。还有更多精彩内容等着你。谢谢你，汤姆。再见。
Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想收听无广告内容、独家番外节目并优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。